foreign
spotted for the first time with
estranged husband Andrew Shu we have a
blended family we have step children
Ex-Wives ex-husbands just days after E.T
learned where Amy and herbo TJ Holmes
stand amid their on-air suspension from
ABC News keeping the romance alive in
any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes right Amy met up with her ex
on a New York City sidewalk to hand off
the family dog she appears to exchange
words with Andrew while he holds on to
their pup now both notably keep a bit of
a distance during their Meetup Amy
called it quits with the actor after 12
years of marriage last summer it was not
easy and sometimes it still isn't easy
meanwhile as for Amy's current romance
with her fellow news anchor E.T has
learned they've lawyered up a source
revealed last week while she and TJ are
still employed at ABC both have hired
attorneys amid the Network's
investigation into their workplace
relationship why well our source
explains because there is an ongoing
investigation and that is what you do
when that happens should you keep your
relationship Under Wraps if you're
dating in the office absolutely the
people in the office do not need to know
it's worth pointing out the president of
ABC News previously said the two haven't
violated any company guidelines now as
for whether TJ and Amy will return to
Anchor gma3 well the source says there's
still a chance they won't quote the
longer this process takes the more
likely they won't return to their
respective positions whether they return
to other positions at the network
remains to be seen it is working chaos
though it all somehow figures itself out
on television but behind the scenes yes
it might seem like a madhouse Amy and
TJ's romance became public in November
when photos surfaced of them showing
some PDA and it drew extra attention
because it was assumed they were both
still married at the time but a source
later explained they'd already separated
from their respective spouses Amy was
already amid her divorce proceeding
things and TJ filed for divorce last
month the day after making headlines the
co-anchors returned to gma3 and TJ
suddenly poked fun at the massive media
attention hey there everybody good
afternoon welcome
to gma3 what you need to know on this
Friday you know it's too bad it's Friday
it's been a great week to keep going and
going and going just to enjoy it but
just days following Amy and TJ got
yanked off the air and have yet to
return instead seems the two got in some
quality time traveling together for the
holidays
foreign